good morning Hank it's Tuesday greetings
from the floor of a hotel room in New
York City congratulations on your book
it is just so so brilliant it really is
the best book I've read about what now
feels like and it's also like a
rip-roaring adventure story to be honest
when you first told me you were writing
a book part of me was like I'm gonna
have to be the big brother in this
situation advising him on writing and
stuff but in the end I can offer you
know writing advice at all only
congratulations in part because our
styles are so different for instance
your book like has a proper plot but but
Hank you have to improve your self
promotion I mean you made a three minute
and 47 second video about your book in
which you failed to mention the title of
your book which by the way is an
absolutely remarkable thing it comes out
on September 25th and is available for
pre-order now say it with me Hank an
absolutely remarkable thing comes out on
September 25th and is available for
pre-order now when you are talking about
your new book even if you are talking to
your spouse or your cat always include
those three pieces of information title
pub date available for pre-order now
also you didn't talk much about the plot
of the book and I definitely understand
the urge to avoid spoilers but the
premise is so so good alright check this
out a 23 year old graphic designer is
walking home from a very late night at
work when she happens across a ten foot
tall seemingly immovable sculpture of
like a samurai warrior she names the
sculpture Carl in a YouTube video she
makes with her friend and then wakes up
the next morning wildly famous in part
because the YouTube video was charming
and funny and in part because 50 other
Carl's have appeared all over earth at
exactly the same time and from there it
just gets amazing it is the story of one
woman's ascent or possibly descent into
Fame and Punda tree and an exploration
of how humans behave when faced with big
shared challenges now Hank I don't want
to criticize your promo game too much
because you are a good person who
understandably doesn't want to bombard
our audience with marketing but this
isn't like an ad for Squarespace which
by the way is your number one
one-stop-shop for websites like Hank
Green Comm you've been working on this
book for years and people want to know
about it obviously vlogbrothers
shouldn't become like a booktube channel
devoted only to one book but do let us
know when like there's a cover god I
cannot wait for the cover also are you
going on tour and can I come and can we
bus again okay lastly and maybe most
importantly in your announcement video
you said this not all pre-orders will be
signed John set unrealistic expectations
all right I get that only someone who
finds arguably pathological joy and
repetitive tasks would sign their name
200,000 times but that doesn't mean that
you should sign 0 pre-orders so yeah
we'll figure something out sorry I had
to go out to get a piece of pizza let's
just resume filming at the hotel room
Hank congratulations again on a great
book I am so excited for the world to
read it and for the important
conversations that will emerge from it
but before I go I have to do a bit of
self promo the first episode of my new
podcast the anthropocene reviewed is out
now and available for your listening
pleasure the anthropocene reviewed is a
podcast where I review different facets
of the human centered planet on a
five-star scale the first episode is
about Canada geese of bird species that
nearly went extinct and diet dr. pepper
a zero calorie soda popularized by a man
named foots it's been really fun to work
on something personal and also a little
weird I hope you like it there are links
in the doobly-doo below hank an
absolutely remarkable thing comes out
September 25th and is available for
pre-order now I will see you on Friday